My name is Hans Moritz Guenther.
I'm going to tell you
about how stars are born
and how we know that.
I'm an astronomer.
I don't know who of you is.
And so I want to not just say--
I don't want to just say
what the result is, I want
to show you how we get there.
And that means that
some of the things I
show you are not
going to look nice.
And that's because, in practice,
research data doesn't usually
look like this.
Sometimes it does,
and that's fantastic.
But often, it doesn't.
So I'm going to tell you,
as I said, how stars form.
I'll tell you how we know that.
And I'll tell you a little
bit about how we actually
work, like the social part
of being an astronomer.
How does science come together?
How do we get that data?
Those types of things.
Because I find that that's
often what people like to know
and I think it's
really interesting
and it's important of
how it goes together.
But when you read
the New York Times
about some great new discovery,
it's not going to be in there.
The pretty picture is
going to be in the--
discovery will be
described there.
But how people actually got
there is usually not in there.
So I want to tell you that.
So how do stars form?
This is the Orion Nebula
cloud, an optical picture
of the Orion Nebula cloud
zoomed in a lot, obviously.
And then, for some
of these pieces,
like this tiny dot
here and this--
find my mouse-- this tiny dot
over there zoomed in even more.
And I'm going to talk
about all these elements
in a little pieces.
I just want to tell you
that star forming regions
are one of the things
that look fantastic.
Now, to orient you a
little bit about what
I'm going to talk
about, here's a cartoon
of the phases of star formation.
Stars form-- I showed you the
picture of the Orion Nebular
cloud-- in these huge
clouds of gas and dust.
And these huge clouds
of gas and dust
exist in our Milky Way today.
Specifically, if you travel
to the Southern hemisphere
and you look at the
Milky Way at night,
there's these Black
patches in the sky.
And that's not because
there's no stars.
Actually, you see on that image
on the wall over there too.
That's not because
there's no stars.
It's because there's
clouds of cold gas and dust
in front of us that cover
up some of those stars.
And when I say
cold gas and dust,
I mean, about 20 to 100 Kelvin.
So that'll be like
minus 200 Fahrenheit.
And when I say dust, it's
like, if you lick your finger
and go like this over
the furniture that
hasn't been cleared, that's
actually pretty similar.
I'll do it outside,
often on this dust,
there's water ice on it.
So if you go outside right now
and you just grab a snowball
and fizzle it up,
that's actually
pretty similar to what
these clouds of gas
and dust in the universe are.
And then, because
these clouds all
depend on little pieces, gas,
particles, and dust clumps
and gravity contracts.
Gravity, all these little
pieces pull on each other
so they contract
towards the middle.
Now, they don't always
go to the same clump,
but they could go
to multiple clumps.
And so you form
this inner cloud.
You form these smaller clump
pieces and these clump pieces
start contracting.
And as they start
contracting, they
get what we call an inner core.
And then, what happens is
when you compress something,
it gets hot.
If you go and fill up your
bicycle with a hand pump
and after your tire
is full, you touch
the valve or you touch
the front of the pump,
it's going to be hot.
That's because every time you
compress the air, it heats up.
And so the same
thing happens here.
And eventually, it gets
denser and denser and denser
and eventually it's
going to get hot enough
that it starts shining
and we can see it.
So that'll be like this inner
bit here, this inner star here.
Now, these gas clouds, these
clouds of gas and dust,
they're never stationary.
There's always flows.
There's ebbs and-- not tides.
But there's flow over
here and flow over there
and there's a big
massive heavy star there
that pulls material up.
And so when you compress it
from 200,000 astronomical units
to just one astronomical
unit, the same thing
happens as if somebody on
the ice pulls their arms in,
or if you want to speak physics,
angular momentum is conserved.
And so a tiny motion over
here gets a really fast
spinning motion in the middle.
And because we have this
really fast spinning motion,
around these central
objects, you form a disk.
And these disks
are the reason why
the planets in our
solar system all
orbit around the sun in the
same way, in the same plane,
because they're all
formed in this disk.
It was random, you
could have one planet
go this way and one planet
go that way.
But that's not what we see
because they're all formed
in this disk that rotate--
all rotate pretty
flat around the sun.
There's a little bit up and down
because it's not exactly flat.
But essentially, all
orbit in the same plane.
And so these are the
disks where planets form,
and that's part of why it's
interesting because we want
to look at how planets form.
There's also outflows
as I'll show you.
And then, we'll get
these rings and gaps.
And eventually, we'll
end up after maybe
50 million years
or so, we end up
with a system as a star in the
middle and a couple of planets
around.
And so the phase I work on is
this phase from here over here
too maybe here.
I'm looking at how this
disk and the stars interact.
Why do we care?
Now, maybe you
think that's cool.
And I think that's cool and
I think it's interesting.
But specifically, when I write
a funding proposal and say,
dear NASA, please
give me $200,000
so I can keep working
on that, I need
to have a slightly
better explanation
than it's cool, right?
So one of the things we
care for is the origin
of planetary systems.
How do planetary
systems form at all?
How do you make planets?
And in order to
understand that, we
need to know what
the conditions are.
Is it hot?
Is it cold?
It is dense?
It is iron?
Is there hydrogen?
What actually is
the stuff made of?
We can also interpret
that as going back in time
because we can't see
today how our Earth was
formed because that was
5 billion years ago.
But we can take a
telescope and look
at stellar systems
for Earth like planets
that are forming today.
And so that looking
at those systems
helps us understand what
the conditions were when
the Earth was formed and how,
potentially, life on Earth
started and things like that.
And one interesting
tidbit or aspect
is that we think--
or one idea is
that life, or at least
certain biomolecules,
may have formed in
space first, and then
come onto the Earth
frozen in as comets.
Not necessarily-- don't
think of an animal walking,
but think of amino acids.
And we know that in these
large clouds of gas and dust
using radio observations,
we can identify
fairly complex molecules.
Originally, people found carbon.
Then they found carbon monoxide.
Then they found carbon dioxide.
But we now have-- we
found benzyl rings.
So six carbon atoms in a
ring, the stuff around it.
We found molecules that have
three benzyl rings on it.
So I don't know--
I don't work on radio.
I don't know what
the latest one is.
But the complexity of chemistry
in these clouds is astonishing.
And so, almost certainly, some
of that rain down on the Earth.
Is that important to
start life on a planet?
I don't know.
But it's certainly
interesting that it's there
and that the
building blocks don't
actually-- or some
of the building
blocks don't necessarily
have to form on a planet
because they're
out there in space
and they're just rained out.
And so, again, for that-- to
understand if that's important,
if that's cool,
if that's useful,
if we want to know
a little bit more
about the conditions of
how stars and planets form.
So how do we do that?
Well, we go and look.
And when we go and look, we
have a choice in how we look.
We have the entire what we
call electromagnetic spectrum.
The thing that's most used
to us is visible light.
That's what we
detect with our eyes.
But there's a whole
range out there.
And the visible light
is just this tiny bit
of area of the spectrum.
It's just this tiny thing here.
There's UV light, there's X-ray
light, there's gamma ray light,
there's a huge range of infrared
light, there's microwaves,
there's radio waves,
I already said.
And radio, we can
identify these molecules.
And by building the
right telescopes
and the right instruments, we
can get a lot more information
than if we were just
looking in visible light.
Here's an on Earth
demonstration of why
that might be interesting.
These are two animals, meerkats
and freshwater crocodiles,
observed in two
different wavelengths.
The top one is visible how
you would see it with your eye
and the bottom one is
an infrared camera.
And you see that although
they look fairly similar
and have fairly similar
color, in visible light,
they look vastly
different in the infrared.
Now, I'm not a biologist, but
if you look closely enough,
that tells you something about
the temperature of the animal
and the skin conditions and
what the skin is made of
and stuff like that if
you look closely enough.
And so we want to
use the analogy,
we want to use the
same thing in space
by looking at more
different wavelengths
to probe more different
properties of these things.
Slight wrinkle.
Many of these wavelengths
don't make it to Earth.
That's good because,
for example,
X-rays, if you have
too many X-rays,
you're going to get cancer
if you get X-rays too much.
So fortunately, the
Earth's atmosphere
blocks most of the X-rays
that come from space.
And unfortunately,
for us, that means
if we want to see the
X-rays that come from space,
we have to build a
satellite and fly it
above the Earth's atmosphere.
That means it's expensive.
The Chandra satellite
that I often work with
or that I work for cost
about $1 to $2 billion,
depending on how
exactly you count it.
And if something is
broken, it's gone.
It's in space.
You can't just
fly up and fix it.
For the Hubble Space
Telescope, where
they went up with
space shuttles to fix
things, every time you go up and
fix something, it's $1 billion.
So it's not like--
you can't just go and tighten
the screw if you need to.
So if you can observe it
from Earth, that's great.
But certain things we just can't
because there's air in between.
And so, not incidentally,
the wavelengths
that make it to Earth
best is the visible light,
which is why our eyes see
visible light because we
have plenty of that there.
But if you want to
observe in several
of these other wavebands, we
have to observe satellites--
near satellite.
So in X-rays, we can use,
for example, Chandra.
There's a second one, a
European one called XMM-Newton.
In the UV, the Hubble
Space Telescope
is still the best one.
And this is a picture of
the James Webb Telescope
that observes in the
infrared recently seen.
So there are solar panels
that power Chandra.
The X-rays go in here.
Chandra doesn't make X-rays.
It's not an X-ray machine.
It's a telescope.
Observes X-rays that
come from space anyway.
The sun makes X-rays,
black holes make X-rays,
and we just need to see them.
And so it's very long.
Chandra was launched
with the space shuttle.
It's actually the heaviest
thing the space shuttle has ever
launched.
And the detectors
are here in the back.
And I can say a little
bit more about how
Chandra is made from--
or how it was made
later if we get to it.
OK, I said we want to observe
in different wavelengths
because they give us
different information.
This is a star forming region.
That's what people call
the Pillars of Creation
in the Eagle Nebula observed
in different wavelengths.
On the left is visible
light observed with Hubble.
This is near-infrared light.
And then, on the far side
is this mid-infrared light,
so even longer wavelengths.
And you see that although
the exact same region,
you see different things.
For example, when you look
in the optical with Hubble,
you see these dense
clouds of gas and dust,
where I told you stars form.
I told you stars last form,
but you don't actually
see that because all
hidden behind that cloud.
When you look in
the mid-infrared,
that dust is transparent.
And because it's transparent,
or mostly transparent,
you can see all these stars
here and you can actually
go up and count them.
And if you go into
the mid-infrared,
then their dust isn't black,
it's actually glowing.
And because it's
glowing, we can now
measure the properties
of the dust.
We can look at the light
that comes from the dust.
We can see how much it
glows or what color it has
and that tells us
what temperature
it has, for example, and that's
how we know how cold it is.
I said it's about
100 Kelvin or so.
That's how we know.
And that's how we know
what it's made of.
Yes.
How do you know that a star is
in the cloud and not behind it?
That's a very good question.
There's several
things we can do.
The easiest is this--
so there is a complex answer.
And not every
technique will work
for every one of those stars.
One of the best things or
easiest things to measure
distances is you
measure-- you point--
you look at it from
here and then you
wait six months until the Earth
is on the other side of the sun
and measure it from
here and there'll
be a difference in angle.
It's called parallax.
And that difference
in angle, you
can use a sign and
elementary geometry
and transform that
to a distance.
So that's one way, for example.
In this particular case,
that's not terribly useful
because it's not that precise
and the Nebula isn't that deep.
But if you can identify
the same star in,
for example, in this
image and in this image,
then you can say, for
example, this one,
you could say there's
lots of stuff behind it,
lots of Nebula.
I can't see anything
else behind it.
So it's clearly in front
of this dense region.
And yet, I can't see it here.
So there must also be still
some material in front of it,
so it's probably in the middle.
That doesn't give me
exactly where it is
and it doesn't give me a 3D map.
But it tells me it's
not far-- at least,
it's not very far behind it.
It's not very far
in front of it.
It's associated with that cloud.
In other clusters that are
further-- that are closer by,
what you can also do is you
can look at how stars move.
Because the galaxy rotates.
Stuff moves around.
And so when you have one of
these clouds and it moves,
then all the objects in it
should move the same way
on the sky.
And things that are far away on
the other end of the galaxies
aren't going to move
in the same direction.
We call that proper motion.
Now, of course, stars
don't move terribly fast.
I mean, if you
look out at night,
if you see something
move, it's not a star.
A typical speed would be--
so we take a degree, right?
One degree of distance is 1
degree is about this much.
A degree consists
of 60 arc minutes.
Each arc minutes consists
of 60 arc seconds.
And now, I can't do
that with my fingers
because I can't
make it that small.
And then, we need it
smaller than that.
So every arc second we pick
down in 1,000 milliarcseconds.
And these stars may move a
tenth of a milliarcsecond a year
or so.
So you do need some big
telescopes and fairly precise
measurements.
But if you can make that
and their satellites that
are purpose built
for just that purpose
and you see that all the
stuff moves together,
then they're probably part
of the same association.
I'll talk a lot about
the Orion Nebula cloud.
I already told you some of
the things of the Orion Nebula
cloud.
So I at least want to
tell you where it is.
Orion is probably
one of the few things
most people can see on the sky.
And even in Boston
you can find Orion
because it's one of the
few that are bright enough
that you can see that.
I know about six constellations
because I find that most
people I talk to three.
So if you know six,
that makes you an expert
and that's good enough
and I don't have
to remember anymore of that.
But Orion has this popular
belt of three stars next to it.
And then, you have the
feet and the hands.
And just down here
is Orion's sword.
And in the middle
of Orion's sword
is this Orion Nebula, this Orion
Nebula that I talked before.
So the Orion Nebula is
actually bright enough
that you can see it visible
by eye if you are, let's say,
in Maine or Vermont or the
Mojave desert or somewhere
it's actually dark.
Don't try in Boston.
Pointless.
But in dark spaces,
you can see it.
OK, so I already showed
you a couple of images.
And one of the techniques
we learn about young stars
is we do images of them.
So here's real images from
the Orion Nebula cloud.
I told you that images-- that
stars have disk around them.
How do we know that?
Well, here's an image
that looks a little bit
like a black saucer or cigar.
What that is is the Nebula
behind it is glowing.
And then, we are looking at
the edge of one of those disks.
And the disk is
colder and denser
than the rest of the Nebula,
so it makes a black shadow.
And so now we can go and we know
how far away Orion is and we
can measure the size of this.
And then, we can
calculate the size
in kilometers of whatever
unit you want to use.
Astronomers often use
centimeters, although numbers
are really high.
We can calculate the size
in centimeters how long
and how thick that is.
Why is this Nebula glowing?
Why is the Orion
Nebula glowing at all?
It's like driving
your car through fog.
It doesn't glow by itself.
There's bright stars that
shine light on the Nebula
and it reflects it to us.
So it's a reflection Nebula.
Here's another one.
And what do you see?
The glowing stuff here in the
middle, that's not the star.
The star is tiny.
The star is tinier than
the tip of the mouse.
But what happens is
that, around this disk,
there's other gas and dust.
The star can't shines
through the disk
because the disk is too thick.
But it shines upward
and stuff gets reflected
and we see the reflected light.
Even more obvious here, the star
itself sits here in the middle
here.
This is the black
disk left and right.
It goes kind of diagonally
that we look at from the side.
And then, this is
all gas flowing out
from the star that
reflects the starlight.
And so we can see now
which direction it goes.
We can see that it's less
here, which is why it's black.
Nothing reflects here.
There's a little more here
we can learn about how
gas flows out from stars.
Here's another thing.
Here, the star sits
here and it has a disk.
And what you can't see because
there's a cutout, way over here
is a very bright star.
This very bright star shines
on that disk and evaporates it.
It's so bright that it,
essentially, boils off material
and then reflects and shines.
And so what you see here is a
reflection from this material
that boils off the disk.
Why do we care?
Well, if you want to
know how planets form,
we need to know how long
these disks survive.
Do you have a million
years to make a planet?
Do you have 100,000
Do you have 10 million
years to have a planet?
And so one thing that
matters is, is there
a bright star nearby that
boils off all the material?
And so we measure
the size of the disk
and calculate the mass
of a disk when there's
a bright star nearby
and when there's
not a bright star nearby.
And we can say, OK, bright stars
are bad for making planets,
at least when
you're close enough.
And now, I'm saying bad.
But of course, you could
imagine working out a number
and saying if the star is this
bright and I'm this far away
then it's going to evaporate
X kilograms per second.
I don't have that number
on top of my head.
I'm not going to bore you
with the exact number anyway.
But you could calculate that.
Yes.
In that picture up there,
that central part you said
is the disk, right?
Either side of the disk,
is that the young star
forming or two other stars?
Here?
On either side
the bright lights.
Those are not-- the
star itself, there's
one star forming
here in the middle.
But you don't see it because
it's behind the disk.
Oh, it's behind the disk.
So if the disk looks
like this, right?
You're looking at the edge of
the disk and the stars here.
The tip of my fingers.
You don't see it.
But there's stuff
going in and out.
There's gas and dust on the
top and the bottom of that.
And so the star
shines on that dust
and it reflects back to you.
Imagine me taking a flashlight
and putting it in the fog
up here.
You're going to see
the fog or the Nebula
up and down below even though
there is no star because star
shines in it from the bottom.
The disk has a
hole in the middle.
And so the light can't make
it through this thick layer
of disk, but it can make it up.
And then, if something
is here that reflects it,
let's say, a piece
of ice, then it
goes in the direction
you can see it.
Is the disk itself
irrelevant to the formation
of the young star?
That's what I'm working on.
So yes it is.
I apologize.
No, no, no need to
apologize, right?
Yes it is.
That's a reasonable question.
That's a question you should
totally write in as a proposal
and find out.
Now, we know some
about it already.
So we probably have to say a
little more than let's do that.
But at this stage, most of the
mass is already in the star.
But if you look at
our Earth today,
there's only planets left
and the disk is gone.
And so we can
measure or calculate
how massive is that
disk and what mass
do we have in our planets.
Just take the mass of Mars and
Earth and Jupiter and Saturn
and add them up.
And there's only about 1% of
the mass of an average disk.
So where is the
rest of the mass go?
Well, some of it falls into
the star and some of it
evaporates off.
And what fraction goes where?
Well, that's what we
try to measure, right?
And that influences
the star in some way.
How exactly, it depends
a little bit on the star.
It could change, for example,
the chemical composition
because these disks that
are made of ice and dust.
Does the gas, like
helium and hydrogen,
does it evaporate off first and
all the metals clump together
and make planets?
Do all the metals
then fold in the star?
Do mostly the gas
falls into the star?
That's what we want to measure.
OK, here's a couple more images.
Here is images of jets.
And I already talked
about proper motion
where you see things
move on the sky.
This is a star-- famous
star called HH30.
And the stars in the middle and
you see the disk on the side
again.
And then, you have this jet--
this really collimated stream
of stuff going up and down.
And here, we can
measure how fast
it's going out from the star
because we have pictures
from 1995, 1998, and 2000.
And so you can take this
dot and measure how far
is this dot from the star.
And then, you can look at the
same dot three years later
and see how far away
from the star is it now
and how far away from
the star is it now.
And if you know how fast
the way that thing is,
how far away it is, then you
can calculate how fast it moves,
and it's around 300
miles per second.
And that tells us, well,
we can take the star
and we can look at the
gravitational energy
and say, where
does it come from?
This jet is not
formed in the disk
because disk doesn't
have enough energy
to make anything that fast.
So this jet must be coming from
very, very close to the star.
And so the material that's
thrown out of the jet
is stuff that's from
the star, or that's,
at least, from the
inner edge of the disk.
It's not something further out.
Now, I'm not going to give
you the answer to everything
because, first of
all, I don't know it.
We also still do
research on that.
And there's also
there's literally
hundreds of people
researching that
and I can't tell you everything
that hundreds of people
have spent the last 50 years
working on in 30 minutes.
But that gives us
information about where
that material comes from.
Now, this is a jet
that I've looked at.
And this is one of
those cases where
I said images don't
necessarily look good.
So this is observed with
the Chandra X-ray telescope.
And every dot-- every gray dot
here-- every light gray dot is
one photon, one piece of light.
Every dark gray dot
is two pieces of light
and every black one is
three pieces of light.
Each of those images is about
a day of looking at that star.
You don't see the star itself.
The star is with
these little X's are.
Or you barely see that's the
star itself because, again,
it's one of those cases
where we are looking
through the disk from the side.
And then, we are interested
in the jet that comes out.
I showed you that
picture before how
the jet moves-- how this
jet moves in the optical
observed as Hubble.
We would like to
know of the jets
that we see in X-rays also move.
So first of all, we
need to find one.
And then, we need to find
a feature that moves.
Look in this gray box here.
In 2001, that's
one piece of light.
In 2005, there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 photons pieces of light.
And then, in 2009,
there's only two.
So I think that means
that it's material
that came from the star that
wasn't there in 2005 that moved
into that position in 2009.
And then, it cooled off and
so it moved out and cooled off
so we can't see it anymore.
Now, that's from two and seven
photons and pieces of light.
So we try our best.
But if you want to
make a pretty picture
in multiple different
images, go ahead, right?
It's going to be hard.
But that's why depending on what
research you do and what you
look at, sometimes it looks
good and sometimes it doesn't.
So what we find is from stuff
like this that things that--
the jets that shine in
X-rays are faster than
the ones that shine
in the optical.
And what we think that
means is that jets are not
like a homogeneous stream.
It's actually layers of streams,
like the layers of an onion.
There's something in the
middle that's faster.
And then, there's an outer
layer that's a little slower.
And a layer further out
that's a little slower
and a layer further out that's
a little slower than that
until you get a very slow
motion out to where the disk is.
And again, that tells us
where it is coming from.
Is it coming from a star?
Is it coming from the disk?
We can measure those things.
OK, back to the
Orion Nebula cloud.
I think I've showed that
picture a couple of times now.
In different images, I've
talked about all the pieces.
Here's an X-ray movie.
So this is a month of looking
at the Orion Nebula cloud.
We see that it's twinkling
and you see that some of them
change colors.
Every one of these
dots is a star.
And you see that they're
becoming brighter and fainter.
I should first say, when
you look with your eye
and you see stars twinkling,
that doesn't mean anything.
It's because the Earth's
atmosphere is in the way.
If you were to take
your eyes into space
and look straight
into space, well, OK,
you'll die because
you need to breathe.
But apart from that,
stars wouldn't--
with very, very few exceptions,
they wouldn't twinkle.
The twinkling is the
motion of gas between us
and the Earth's atmosphere
as wind and high layers
that refract the
light and break it.
So it's actually
very annoying when
you do telescope
observations on ground.
You have to try to correct that.
But in X-rays, stars
become brighter and fainter
significantly.
Like sometimes, they
become 20 times brighter.
And so you see
things appearing here
that weren't even there before.
We can show that
in a different way.
And that different way is
what we call a light curve.
So what we do is we have
the time at the bottom.
In this case, in a unit
called kiloseconds, right?
Because that's what you do.
You do meters, centimeters,
and kilometers.
That would be clearly
be grams and kilograms.
So that would be
seconds and kiloseconds.
But whatever.
And so we measure how bright
it is at this time when
we start measuring.
And then, we measure how
bright it's here and how bright
it's here and how
bright it's here
and we measure how
bright it's there.
And it suddenly
becomes a lot brighter.
And we call that
a stellar flare.
We see this in
X-rays, and sometimes,
we see it in the optical,
although in the optical
they're not as strong, you
wouldn't-- they're so weak,
you wouldn't see
them with your eyes.
How do we know what that means?
Well, it'd be great if
there was a star nearby
where we could see what
those things actually mean.
Turns out there is one, and we
see it every day, it's the sun.
So here's a similar
event on the sun.
This is taken with a
satellite called SDO.
And you see these
arc loops here.
Now, I've picked one where
these arc loops happen
to be on the side of
the sun because then you
can see it much better than
when it's in the middle
and the sun is behind.
These are magnetic field lines.
The sun has a magnetic field.
And there is, essentially,
a North Pole over here
and a South Pole over there.
And then, along these
magnetic field lines,
the gas can heat up.
And when it heats up, this is a
movie taken in the ultraviolet,
then becomes hot enough to
shine in the ultraviolet.
So I'll play it again.
And you see that depending
on what the magnetic field
lines do, more and more of
these arcs can light up.
And so you can imagine, if I
take the entire image together
and say, how bright
is that image all over
without knowing that, now
it's brighter than when
I started the movie.
So we can look at
the sun where we
have actually a lot of
detail how these flares go
and then we say,
OK, it's probably
happening very
similar on other stars
except other stars are brighter
and the magnetic fields
are stronger and we
can compare them.
Here's another one.
So we call a coronal
mass ejection.
It's stuff flying out
of the sun-- matter
flying out of the sun.
Now you might imagine if that
hits a planet, that might
do something to the planet.
[INAUDIBLE]
In fact, it does.
These particle and these
coronal mass ejections,
when they hit the Earth, the
Earth has a magnetic field.
And the magnetic
field of the Earth
shields us for most of that.
But the really strong
of those effects--
the really strong
of those things,
they can knock out satellites.
They disrupt satellite
communication.
If they were even
stronger, the strongest one
that Earth has experienced is
called the Carrington Event
after a guy named Carrington
who wrote a lot about it.
That was in the
late 1800s, shortly
after the US had the
first telegraphy lines.
And the magnetic field wobbled
so much that the telegraph
lines started giving sparks
in all directions and people
got hurt from standing
close to the machines.
Now, if you imagine doing
that to the internet
today, where we are
far more connected
and have far more data lines and
have electric wires everywhere,
it's not clear what
that will do to us.
We just hope it doesn't happen.
That's an important part.
But so understanding
stellar activity,
how likely these events
are, how big they are,
how can we prevent them does
have practical applications
to us too.
OK, another thing we can
do is we can do spectra.
We can look at
spectra, another tool.
And so spectra is
just the color--
this is the spectrum of the sun.
If you look at the
sun close enough
and then you put it through
a prism or through--
split it out in the rainbow.
Or 10 years ago, I would
tell people to take a CD
and sprinkle the
rainbows everywhere.
If you look close
enough, you're going
to find these black
lines in them.
They're called Fraunhofer lines
after a guy named Fraunhofer
who discovered them first.
And it turns out
each of those lines
is specific to a
specific element.
So this one, for example, is
sodium in the orange here.
And that has something to do
with how an atom has a nucleus
and has electrons around it
and the electrons go like one
level up or one level down.
And that's a specific
change in energy.
And every specific
change in energy
is a specific color of light.
Fortunately, we can
do the same experiment
at home or in the lab
and we can measure which
element goes with which color.
And then, we can
say, oh, this star
has a lot of very strong line--
a very strong dip or vice
where we expect sodium.
So this star must
have a lot of sodium.
You can, in fact, do some of
those experiments at home.
If you have a gas stove,
the flame is blue.
And if you take some
sodium chloride or salt,
if you take some salt
and dribble it in,
the flame will become orange.
It's a great
experiment for kids.
I mean, an adult has to do
it because you have to get
pretty close to the flame.
But that's the
closest you'll see
atomic physics in your kitchen.
And so we do that for
a bunch of elements
and compare that to what
we measure in the lab.
And then, it can tell us what
elements are stars made of.
And so we know
the sun has mostly
hydrogen and has some sodium
and has iron and has lithium
and has all sorts of things.
And we can measure how much does
this star, have how much does
that star have, does it change
with the age of the star,
does it change with the
star having planets or not
having planets?
We can compare those things.
This is a spectrum how
it looks on the X-rays.
And there's other
elements and I just
want to show you that
that's how they look.
I don't want to go
through every new line
and tell you what they do.
I just want to
show you some data
that I have personally
worked on so you
get an idea of how it looks.
That means most of my
work looks like this.
Now, astronomers do
not wear lab coats
and we don't work all at night.
Very, very rarely people
actually use telescopes.
I mostly use space
telescopes so I don't ever
get to look through them.
I don't ever get to go anywhere.
People I work with, some of them
use ground based telescopes,
like in Chile, for example.
And fortunately, we don't
have to fly to Chile for that
anymore.
People used to fly to Hawaii to
use the telescopes in Hawaii.
And while I would love to
go to Hawaii at some point,
people tell me if you
go 10 times a year,
it's not fun anymore.
Because you fly out from here.
You are 12 hours off.
12 hours jetlagged, right?
You have one day to
get used to Hawaii.
Then, you get to the
bottom of the mountain,
then you have a day to
get up the mountain.
Then, you need to get
jetlagged by another 12 hours
because now you suddenly
have to work at night.
Because that's when you
use your telescopes, right?
And then, you do it
all in reverse again.
And so people would fly
to Hawaii or to Chile
for just one night
of observations.
And that's not just
expensive and a pain,
it's also a huge
carbon emission.
And I'm very glad we
have the internet today
and don't have to do
that very often anymore.
Sometimes you do.
If you build your own
instrument with very specific
instrumentation, you need to go
and screw it on the telescope,
then you need to
be there, right?
But for many cases, many
things can be done remotely.
Most of the data, all
the data is from space.
All the data NASA has taken
you can go and download.
It's all public.
It's all free.
I'm not sure it's useful to you
because the file format might
be a little bit obscure,
but you can do that.
And so I work in an office.
I write code.
Most of my time, I've write
Python code I've write text.
That's my job
OK, specifically, for
space telescopes, I said--
and I know I'm running
five minutes over,
but I'm almost done.
So the way Hubble
works or Chandra works,
there's only one
Hubble and it's not
owned by any particular person.
So how do we get to use it?
We essentially, once a
year, NASA writes proposals.
So we write a letter that,
essentially, goes like this.
Dear NASA, I would like
to look at IM loop.
I think IM loop is
a really cool star.
OK, a little better than that.
IM loop is a star that
is older than-- younger
than TW Hydra and that has
signs of a disk of accretion.
We've looked at TW Hydra before.
And we want to know if
what we've seen there,
if that's true for
all young stars
or only for stars that
are 10 million years old
and if younger stars
behave slightly different.
Then, I go that
and I send it in.
And some group of people
is going to look at.
That because every
year, NASA gets
people asking for about nine
years or eight years of data.
Now, there's only
365 nights a year.
So there's only so much
you can do about it.
There is some committee
that ranks them and says,
this is the most likely
and this is a crap idea
and this won't
work, technically.
And this one we like, but we
just didn't have any time left.
And so you send it in-- for
Chandra, you send it in March.
Then, in June, you get an
email back that says, sorry,
we're not going to do it.
And we aren't going to do
it because you didn't really
describe how long you need to
look or something like that.
So next March in
the second year,
you can update your proposal.
You can send it in again
and explain that better.
Let's say the second time
the committee accepts it.
Now, that goes in
annual cycles, right?
Your star isn't even
visible all the time
because sometimes it's behind
the sun and stuff like that.
So the stuff that gets
approved in June gets
observed sometime between August
and the August the year after.
So depending on how that
falls, in this particular case,
it took-- even
after I sent it in,
it took a year and two months
for me to get that data.
Then, I take that data and I
observe it and I analyze it.
Took me a couple
of months to think
about what it really means.
And then, I've write
it up in a journal.
And now I go and say, OK,
maybe we need to look at a star
that's even younger or that's
an age between IM loop and TW
Hydra that has a higher
mass or lower mass
or something like that.
And then, I write
another proposal.
Why do I tell you this?
Well, A, that means a
timeline is very, very long
between when you
start-- when you
have an idea what you want to
look at until you actually do.
It's even hard to squeeze
into a single PhD.
And second, that's
why most of us
work on at least a dozen
projects at the same time.
Because after I wrote
this in year one,
it's not like I twiddle my
thumb between March that year
and the March next year.
I need to have
other things to do.
Said that already.
OK, and then, we
try to interpret it.
In this particular
case, this is IM loop.
There's these flares
here in the UV
and there's flags
in the X-rays here
that suddenly becomes
a lot brighter.
And so that tells us something
about the magnetic field
of the star.
And then, what do we
do with these results?
Well, we tell people about it.
One of the things we do is we
go to conferences where there'll
be hundreds or
dozens of astronomers
and they work on-- some of them
work on radio observations.
Some of them work on
optical observations.
And so you looked--
I looked at IM
loop in the X-rays.
You looked at IM
loop in the radio.
You learned something
about the disk.
I learned something
about the star.
How does it fit together?
So one of the
things people do is
they give a talk, like I do now,
although usually not as long.
It's often just 10
minutes or so because you
don't have to explain
all the way around
because everybody
there has worked
on young stars for
at least five years.
Or we make it a
poster where we just
write the stuff so that you
can grab your colleagues
and say, hey, come over
here come look what I did.
And then, say, look what I did.
And then, we hold it
next to each other.
And then, ultimately, we
write it in a publication.
We communicate a lot by
email with other people.
And then, we write it into what
we call a publication, a paper.
Although we call it paper,
although it's not on paper.
None of them is printed anymore.
They stop printing
five years ago.
It's all electronic only.
You have a question or remark?
So when you get to use the
telescope for some amount
of time, only you can use it.
And that's because the--
NASA
Data you get is a very
small slice of the sky.
For most telescopes.
The answer depends a little bit
on the telescope, but usually.
And so when I say use,
for the Chandra Space
Telescope or Hubble, what I do
is I fill a web form that says,
look at this star this
camera for that long.
And then, I don't
actually have to know
where that star is in the sky.
I can't tell you where IM lupus.
It's in lupus.
I don't know where lupus is.
It's probably in the Southern
hemisphere somewhere.
I think it is.
I hope it is.
But somebody else
takes care of that
because it's not like any
random person can use a joystick
and move Hubble around, right?
This ground-based telescope,
that's a little different.
Specifically, if you go--
you are a little
closer to the controls
and you actually press a button
and make the thing rotate.
OK, so just before
the end, what can you
do if you care for astronomy?
Well, one important
thing is to be excited.
To like it.
To listen to me and other people
and find out what it's about.
You can observe
the sky yourself.
We greatly appreciate
if the sky stays dark
because it's much easier
to see when it's dark
outside than when it's light.
So for example, around
in Arizona, there's
an observatory on
Kitt Peak that used
to be a fantastically dark sky.
But suburban developments, and
in particular, big box shopping
malls are coming closer
and closer and closer.
And for some reason,
all those parking lots
need to be lit 24/7.
And most of them are lit
with lights that don't just
shine down that also shine up.
That's a problem.
More recently, Starlink.
If you want to launch 20,000
satellites in the sky,
they're going to
visceral pictures.
They already do.
On X-rays we are fine because
they don't emit X-rays.
And also, our X-ray satellites
are even further out.
But with optical
telescope, you constantly
have images where there's
just streaks of right
through because there's all
these satellites going through.
Pay taxes, right?
Because that's what
pays our salary.
That's what-- I said
satellites are expensive.
And there's amateur astronomers,
who we sometimes work with.
This is one as RW Raj's star.
And this is, again,
a light curve
in different bands, which
is why the different colors
and different filters.
And so those are people who just
are interested in astronomy.
They observe this star.
Some of them every night,
some of them only every
now and then.
And then, the upload how
bright it was when they
looked at it in that database.
And even years later,
I can go and say,
now I have something interesting
about how [INAUDIBLE]..
I wonder what it did in the
last couple of years before?
And I pull this data and
say, oh, this isn't actually
the first time it
suddenly became dimmer.
It already went
very dim over here.
I wonder what that means?
But if nobody looks,
I wouldn't have known.
There's also things
you can go through--
so other astronomical
data and help
like look at classified like
on an iPhone app and say,
this looks like two stars.
There's one over here
and one over here.
Whereas, in other
pictures, there's only one.
And why does it matter?
Well, there's a good camera.
We can see it's two pin
stars as good resolution.
If you look at it with the
infrared telescope where
everything is a little
more washed out,
you might-- these two
stars might shine together.
And so you see it's bright,
but it's actually bright
because it's two stars.
It's not because
the one is bright.
And so there's
programs like that
where you can do observations
or look at observations if you
want, OK?
Stars form in large
molecular clouds.
Young stars are
surrounded by disks.
And these disks form planets,
or the stars form planets,
we don't.
But we observe planet formation.
Young stars have these
powerful outflows, these jets
that drive stuff into space.
Star formation happens
right now in the Milky Way.
It's not over.
Even though our Earth is
old, stars and planets
are still forming
almost everywhere.
And we do many
different observations.
We use different
telescopes so we can
look at different wavelengths.
We can look at different
aspects to better understand
how that works.
Are you able to see stars
forming in other galaxies
as well?
Yes.
I mean, I don't
because I specialize
in stars in our galaxy.
And in other galaxies,
they're just so far away
that it's hard to see.
So in other galaxies, you
only see the brightest
and most massive stars.
Things like our sun you wouldn't
see in a different galaxy.
But things that are hundreds
times as massive in the sun you
would.
So things like our sun you
don't see individually.
But if there's many of
them, you see them all
mushed together, right?
So we know that happens.
We know that star form
in other galaxies.
We have this most
together images.
I personally study
things where I can say--
where I can look
at individual stars
and get-- instead of
many thousands of stars
and do a sample and do
a statistic over them,
I look at individual
stars that you
can look at in great detail.
So I don't, but in
principle, we do.
This is a little far afield.
Do you know anything about that
there was a graduate student,
I think, in New Orleans.
I saw this a news
story in BBC who
discovered this
cluster of galaxies
in a structure of a ring.
And she said that
it's significant
because it threatens the
belief that the basis
for the standard model
of particle physics
that allows a uniform.
I read that too.
Did you hear about this?
But I don't know
any more about it
than what was in the
newspaper article.
OK, I was just curious.
Yeah, I can say a
couple more things.
I have a couple of
thoughts on that.
But let me go.
If there's anything
that's related
to this talk first, and then--
I mean, if nobody else
has any questions,
I can say a few things.
No?
OK, then Thanks for coming.
You're welcome to stay and talk
with me as long as you want.
But you also don't have
to feel obliged to sit-in
your desk just because
I'm in your chair
just because I'm talking because
I know I've already run over.
So feel free to run off.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
So the basic idea is that
in the early universe,
we have the Big Bang.
And so stuff starts expanding.
But if you had a structure,
let's say, a ring or disk
or not a disk like this, but
some material of thousands
of galaxies, something
over here and over here,
if they look the same,
if they're connected,
how do they actually
talk to each other?
Because a million years
after the Big Bang,
light can only
make it a distance
of a million light years.
So if, let's say, this--
today, like in my
star forming regions,
stuff-- if there's a bright
star, it shines on this star.
It illuminates it.
This star evaporates and
that all makes sense.
But if this star can't see this
one because the universe isn't
old enough for the light to go
from here to there, how would
this star know anything
about this one?
Could there just be something
in the structure of space time
itself that organizes?
We think, or the current idea
is that information-- nothing
can travel faster than
the speed of light.
Gravitational waves don't
travel faster than light.
The structure of space
time doesn't travel faster
than the speed of light.
So any structure that's bigger
than the age of the universe
times the speed of light at
the time when it was formed
shouldn't be there.
Oh, you're arguing that.
That's the basic idea of
the basic problem, right?
And so, the headline I
read from that article
I think I read on the New
York Times instead of BBC.
So the text is slightly
different, right?
But it's based on the
same press release
that's from the AAS conference
last week in New Orleans.
The basic idea is
that they argue
that the structure is older--
is so old that at the time
light didn't have enough time
to travel from one end
to the other over the age
of the universe at that time.
So that structure shouldn't have
formed because the universe--
there was no way information
could have communicated around.
In the inflationary
model of the universe,
isn't the universe
expand faster?
It does, but it does so
for the first billions
of a second or something like
that or millionths of a second.
There wouldn't be galaxies.
Now, I don't work
on early cosmology,
so maybe it's a millions, maybe
it's 100,000th of a second.
But it's tiny-- it's
too early for that.
There's multiple other things
that could be going on.
And I don't know.
And I'm sure these people
have looked into that
but I don't know.
One thing that has
happened in the past
is that people see structures
when there aren't any.
This ring looks very good.
But if I were to just throw like
chalk pieces on the chalkboard
and you didn't know
how I made that,
you're probably going to
find some structure in that.
You just need to look
at the night sky.
People see the Orion there
or they see Leo or they see--
and there clearly isn't a line
up there and those stars have
nothing to do with each
other because they aren't--
we see them on sky.
There are even stars that
look close on the sky.
One of them is over
here and the other one
is far out over there.
They have nothing to
do with each other.
So the eye-- our eye is
trained to recognize patterns.
Now, people know that and
there are statistical tests
you can try to do that.
I'm sure the people who wrote
this article have done that.
But it's certainly
a thing people
will look into very
carefully and say,
what's the probability of
that just being by chance?
Now, the image I saw on
the press and these rings
looks pretty good.
But I haven't seen
the original images
and I'm not an
expert in that field.
So I said I'd give
you some thoughts,
but I don't have an
authoritative , answer?
Right I mean, if you imagine
going from this image
to something that
looks more like--
I'm looking for drawing.
Looks more like this.
There is some processing
that happened in between to--
that we are not cheating
in the sense that,
for example, why is the
near-infrared red and blue?
Our eyes can't
see near-infrared.
So we need to assign
a color to it.
Like the doctor does when you
do X-rays of a broken hand.
They print it and
black and white
or they could print
it in red and blue
or whatever color they like.
You just need to print
it in some color scale
that the eye can see.
Because x-rays aren't-- they
aren't red or blue or white.
They're just X-rays.
And our eyes can't see them
so they don't have a color.
They have X-ray color
but we can't see that.
So just like an Instagram
filter where everything--
you can turn everything that's
green into blue and everything
that's blue into green.
You can do that.
And so we turn
everything that's X-rays
into green and everything
that's mid-infrared into blue
or something.
And so that's processing that
happens to make it visible.
You have to make sure
that's processing is right.
And I'm sure that people who
did the research tried that.
But then, when you just
see the image on the BBC,
it's probably the more
processed version.
So you would want to see how
the less processed version looks
like, right?
Light what we're seeing.
I don't know which
image they used.
They just say there's
many steps in between.
And if you want to
understand the details,
you have to look
at all those steps.
And I haven't done that.
And so I'm going to stop
speculating now, right?
Because I don't know
any more than that.
If you're making us
aware of that then
we can't just look
at an image and think
that's what we would see
if we were above the dust.
I mean, we're not--
we didn't draw these images.
We didn't make them up.
But we clearly manipulated them
to make things more visible
and stand out the same
way as you would--
when you post
something on Instagram,
you put a filter that softens
it or highlights the background
or reduces that solar glare
and gives you the more
details in the faint parts or
that highlights the solar glare
and removes all the
details in the faint part.
So there are steps
in between, depending
on what you want to look at.
So then, we have
actually know the colors
that we see accurately
if we go to the space.
It's not that--
It's not going to
look like that.
Part of that is--
so even the visible
light, this is using
a 2 point-- this is Hubble.
It's a 2.4 meter telescope.
The pupil of your eye
is about this big.
And Hubble looked at
that for about an hour
or two hours or
something like that.
And so you collect
all this light
for a very, very long period of
time using a really big mirror.
If you look the same
way with your eye,
you are going to just
see the light that
instantly arrives in this area.
And you can test that
by looking at something
you can see with your eye.
Go out where it's dark and
look at the Orion Nebula.
And while I tell you that the
Orion Nebula is somewhere.
Well, I tell you that
this is the Orion Nebula.
It's not going to look like that
when you look with your eye.
It's going to be a little fuzzy
thing look at another image.
Now, this is a little closer.
But go to the other end of the
room and take your glasses off.
And that's probably
closer to what you
would see with your naked eye.
On Earth, you use
a magnifying glass.
That doesn't mean
it's fake, it just
means it's seen through
a magnifying glass.
Or in my case, through
our glasses, right?
I see you better this way.
That doesn't mean
it's a fake image,
it just means I see you through
your glasses whereas now I
don't.
And so, similarly,
there's magnifying,
there's longer exposures,
and there is filters that--
think of it as
polarizing glasses
that take out the solar glare.
That doesn't mean doesn't mean
it's fake, it just means--
or sunglasses.
You use sunglasses to make it a
little darker so your eyes can
see it better.
Now, the same thing we
can do with telescopes.
Doesn't mean it's wrong.
It just means it's
seen through a filter.
And the young star
you're looking at,
it has a lower left.
This has thousands
of young stars.
No, the one you were looking at.
So the ones I've looked
at aren't actually
on this picture, the ones
I've personally worked on.
Are they in the Orion Nebula?
I work on some with the
Orion Nebula, but they said--
I don't know where they are.
They're probably over here.
So I work in X-rays and this
is like an optical image.
This is an optical image.
But are they in that area?
Some of them are in that area.
But the Orion
Nebula is already--
it's not far away.
But since I want to
study individual stars
for as much detail as I can,
I look for the closest one
to look at.
That in near the belt
of the Orion Nebula,
there are a lot of
young stars forming.
That is true, though, that is a
good hotspot for a young star.
I showed you where it was.
Yeah, you showed
us where it was.
Right down there, right?
And Orion's Nebula.
That's it.
That's not where that star
you were looking at is.
That one.
I've looked at dozens of
stars in different locations
including--
We're talking about.
The IM Loop?
No.
I IM Lupus And Lupus,
if it wasn't Orion,
it would be called
something something Ori.
Oh, got it.
OK.
So the star is in Orion.
The brightest one is A Ori.
The second brightest,
B Ori, C Ori, D Ori.
And then, sometimes,
they just get a number.
If they're variable,
they start with V.
And then, it's V12748 Ori
or something like that.
OK, Thank you.
Can I ask you something?
Of course.
What is important to have this
connection between discussed--
so you were mentioning that in
the formation of the universe.
So you have two stars that
they might be connected or have
connection?
Is that important?
So I mean, is it important?
We try to find out
what it is, right?
The universe is what it is.
We're not going to
make a new universe.
But in this particular
case, and it won't be stars,
it'd be galaxies.
But I mean, the same idea.
You have two objects.
And if these two objects
can't talk to each other
because there wasn't enough
time for them to exchange
light or information-- no
information travels faster
than light, we think.
If there was no time to
exchange information,
they shouldn't be
related to each other.
They should have
formed independently.
Because if they're
related to each other,
let's say, if this star--
the stars, right?
If this star
evaporates that one,
light needs to have time to
go from this one to that one.
Otherwise, it can't
evaporate or the light
can't make it because the
universe isn't old enough yet.
Now, this I'm going to be stars
because the universe grows
pretty fast.
It's going to be galaxies
that talk to each other.
But the same idea is if
they form like a structure,
like a perfect ring on
the sky, then that ring
must have formed,
we think, at a time
when there was some event
that made that ring.
I don't know.
Explosion in the
middle or something
that made them all
form at the same time
or something like that.
If the structure formed when
the universe was so young
that nothing could have gone
between here from there,
why are they on
this perfect ring?
What made them go on that ring?
They should be randomly located.
And the probability of
randomly making a ring
or randomly making a
triangle or whatever you want
is pretty low.
So if you find
structures that look
as if there is some
causality, some
cause that made
this structure, then
the universe should
have been old enough
that cause can actually
propagate information
from, I don't know, an
explosion or whatever it is.
Let's take an explosion
as an example.
Let's say there's an explosion
in the middle and the shock
wave that comes out and
that forms something.
Then, that can only
happen if-- when
it formed, if the
universe was old enough
for the shock to actually go
from the middle to the outside.
Otherwise, that won't work.
So if there's nothing can go
from the middle to the outside,
how would we get like a
perfect ring of galaxies?
That inflationary
rate of expansion
was too far in the past to
have accounted for that.
There are certainly things
that are related to that.
There's some things called
baryon acoustic oscillations
that have to do
with this inflation.
But I'm not an
expert on inflation
and I'm not going to
derive the equations
of the inflationary universe
on a Blackboard now.
Maybe Alan Guth will
respond at some point.
Maybe.
As I say, this particular
press release from last week,
I'm sure lots of people
are going to look at it.
We'll keep our
attention focused.
OK.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]